[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مع مرور الايام
يعني
مثل ما بيقولوا باللغه العربيه الفصحى
يغرق في لجنه الياس شيئا فشيئا
ولكن
بالاعماق بالاعماق يعني بضل
باخر النفق في بصيص صغير انه في يومين ما
بدي اطلع اتابع حياتي واتابع مسيري يعني
هذا الامل يبقى موجود
[موسيقى]
لكن كما سمعتك في احدى المقابلات تقول انه
المعتقل يغادر السجن ولكن السجن لا
يغادرون لا يغادر لا يغادره ابدا هو معك
حتى الان حتى الان يعني لم يكن بنفسي لم
يكن بنفس الحد غير
لا ولكن ذكرى او بالتعب النفسي هي ندبه
موجوده في النفس الانسانيه تبقى
الانسان عايش فتره احيانا كتير يعني في
البدايات وقت تطلع من السجن بالبدايه
هاي سميتها حكيت عنها مره انا من اللحظه
هاي اللي بين اليقظه والنوم وانت تكون
نايم
وبدك تفيق من نومك
بتحس حالك انه انت بالسجن لسه هيك بدك
ثانيه
حتى تنتبه انه لا هذا خلاص انتهى الموضوع
كابوس كابوس اجواء سجن كله
[موسيقى]